CHICAGO.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: IT'S SAD FOR PEOPLE
THAT LOVE THE CITY OF CHICAGO.
PEOPLE SHOULD.
IT'S AN AMERICAN CITY.
A GREAT PLACE IN A LOT OF WAYS.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE MURDER RATE.
WE TALKED VERY LITTLE ABOUT THE
PHYSICAL FIT.
CHICAGO IS INFESTED WITH RATS.
ONE CHICAGO ANIMAL SHELTER IS
RELEASING FERAL CATS TO GET THE
RATS UNDER CONTROL.
>> ORKIN HAS NAMED CHICAGO THE
RATTYEST CITY IN AMERICA.
THEY HAVE THE CATS AT WORK
PROGRAM, FERAL CATS THAT PREFER
TO BE SOCIALLY DISTANCE.
>> THEY WON'T THRIVE IN A HOME
ENVIRONMENT.
>> THE COST RANGES FROM $600 TO
$800.
>> Tucker: SO THE SHELTER IS FOR
A FEE PLACING TWO TO THREE CATS
OUTSIDE OF BUSINESSES AND
RESIDENCES THAT CALL FOR HELP
WITH RATS.
SEEMS INSPIRED.
DOES IT WORK?
WE WANTED TO TALK TO SOMEONE
THAT WOULD KNOW THE ANSWER.
JORDAN REED IS A RAT WRANGLER.
HE SAID DOGS WOULD BE MORE
EFFECTIVE.
MR. REID, THANKS FOR COMING ON.
BEFORE YOU GET TO YOUR
PREFERENCE, DOGS OVER CATS,
FERETS, DESCRIBE ABOUT THE RAT
PROBLEM.
>> I DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT IT.
I'M ON THE WEST COAST.
I GET A LOT OF CALLS INVITING ME
TO COME OUT.
>> Tucker: THAT'S THE POINT.
YOU'RE 1,000 MILES AWAY.
THE CITY OF CHICAGO -- THAT'S
HOW DESPERATE THEY ARE BY THE
NORWAY RAT PROBLEM.
WHEN YOU HEAR OF PEOPLE
RELEASING FERAL CATS TO KEEP
RATS UNDER CONTROL, YOU CHUCKLE
TO YOURSELF, DON'T YOU?
THE IGNORANCE.
>> A LITTLE BIT.
FERAL CATS ARE WELL-KNOWN FOR
THE PROBLEMS THAT THEY CAUSE THE
NATIVE SPECIES.
THEY'RE NOT KNOWN FOR CATCHING
RATS.
>> Tucker: YEAH, BY THE WAY,
ANYBODY DEEPLY FAMILIAR WITH
FERAL CATS WOULD KNOW THAT.
WHAT WOULD YOU RECOMMEND?
>> WELL, I LIKE TO PROMOTE THE
USE OF DOGS.
I'M WELL-KNOWN FOR MY WORKOUT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND OREGON.
THE USE OF TERRIERS AS WELL AS
DEALING WITH THE MANAGEMENT
PROBLEMS THAT IS CREATING THE
RATS.
>> Tucker: TERRIERS AS THEY WERE
CALLED IN GREAT ARE BRITAIN SO
LONG AGO, RATTING DOGS.
HOW MANY RATS CAN A WELL-TRAINED
RATTING DOG, A TERRIER, TAKE OUT
IN THE COURSE OF AN EVENING
WOULD YOU SAY?
>> I OFTEN TAKE MY DOGS OUT
THREE OR FOUR HOURS BUT TO FARM
LOCATIONS.
I'VE CAUGHT IN EXCESS OF SEVERAL
HUNDRED WITH THREE OR FOUR YEARS
ADULT DOTS.
>> Tucker: DO YOU LET YOUR DOG
EAT THEM?
>> NO, SIR.
JUST IN CASE OF POISONING.
TRAINING TO DROP IS ONE OF THE
FIRST COMMANDS THAT THEY LEARN.
>> Tucker: SO LIKE A BIRD DOG.
YOU DON'T EAT THE QUAIL.
YOU DROP IT AT THE FEET OF YOU
REMEMBER MASTER.
>> I JUST GO AROUND AND COLLECT
THEM AFTER THEY'RE DEAD.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU DO WITH
THEM?
>> WE GIVE THEM TO FALCONERS OR
COMPOST THEM.
>> Tucker: NOTHING IS WASTED.
USE THE WHOLE RAT.
I LIKE THAT.
LAST QUESTION.
WHAT DO YOUR DOGS THINK OF IT?
HOW PROUD ARE THEY AFTER KILLING
200 RATS IN A NIGHT?
>> I WOULD ANSWER THAT QUESTION
BY SAYING THE REASON I HAVE
CHOSEN THIS AS MY FUN ACTIVITY
IS BECAUSE I'M EMBRACING THE
TRUE NATURE OF THE DOGS.
IT'S MY BELIEF THAT THIS IS IN
THE NATURE OF THE ANIMAL.
BECAUSE I LIKE TERRIERS, I HAVE
TO GIVE THEM AN ACTIVITY.
>> Tucker: I LOVE THAT.
I LOVE DOGS, TO